why does happen in boat harbour is
definitely environmental racism this
happens across Canada way too often with
our First Nations communities and you
know a corporation will come in and they
will they will do what they can to
extract the resources that they need
another time when the Strait is a
breeding ground for lobsters and for
herring and mackerel and rock crab
everything that at our community fish is
on right so if we if we go in there and
destroyed the habitat for them to to
reproduce in that we're we're generally
gonna be people from the reserve they've
they've been fighting this for 51 years
and it's it's the fishermen the
non-native fishermen that have been
joining them it's just this mill is no
good the pipeline it's gonna ruin our
fishery yeah we all came together for
common interests for too long they try
to take advantage of First Nations
people but it's gonna come to a stop
because First Nations people across this
nation are rising up
[Music]
little food food more bad
[Applause]
everybody's ready
[Music]
we're throwing this trying to fall
follow-up the top on that survey vote
right there that's coming in it'll tell
our fishing date they'll know what the
bottoms like they can leave that
pipeline in right and the only way we're
going to evil stop this is to stop that
from surveying the ocean floor they
probably never ever thought they'd have
this much resistance this whole area
depends on fishing it's a number one
aiming industry for Northern Nova Scotia
my name is Warren Patrick Francis I've
allowed you to meet my tribe I'm from
pixel an impersonation I'm a
self-employed fisherman our community
has been dealing a lot of asthma a lot
of breathing problems and I blame it all
on this this plant here we didn't live
in 50 years with this garbage northern
pop news is a bleaching process to make
their paper white they have to get rid
of all the stuff that comes out of the
wood like all the discoloration and all
the heavy solubles and stuff like that
and they've got to take it somewhere to
be treated and then they got to dump it
somewhere because it's too caustic to
run through their pipes
when the water first gets here from from
the plant it takes 28 days to get here
and go throughout the whole process and
to leave it to the Northumberland Strait
there the new system they're proposing
is is only gonna take a few hours and
then I'm gonna pump it straight out to
the street
the smell is horrible I mean I've even
breathed this through my bowels so I
don't have to smell it but the steam and
everything that's coming off this hot
water is just oh it's sickening
[Music]
this fire corner here is where our
reserve is located and right here is
Boat Harbour where the treated effluent
goes into it's not even a kilometer so
we've been living with this just poison
in all our lives we've shot the air
rabbits and then when we go to gut them
and we find love to them so he said to
the DNR for testing then they're full of
cancers we're gonna check the clarity in
the water this is where the elf fall for
both Harbor which treats northern pups
flloyd this goes out to that
Northumberland Strait and this stuff
stuff like this that's been going to the
strange and that water is very clean
you can see it even purple there
[Music]
there's a to families in there that that
fish and this were a fisheries manager
lives and his white bitches and the
other guy he works for my brother in
fishin that he's employed by fission
this fight isn't just with the fishermen
it's with our community as well and just
the leader of our community chief
engineer Paul which is my sister that
she's the voice of our people because
we've dealt with this for such a long
time Trust is such a big word in the
community people don't trust the water
so a lot of people won't drink out of
their taps because they they're worried
that you know maybe there's
contamination in our water people don't
trust the air and then there's the trust
of the soil if I plant a garden is it
safe to eat and that's been a huge one
traditionally that's what people did
right we planted food we we fished we
hunted and we gathered our traditional
medicines all of those were were taken
away from us they had farms and
everything else and everybody shared to
work everybody shared to you with the
profits we're strong healthy people now
we're all full of cancer and whatnot and
there's a lot of people that have died
from it already but there's not nothing
that says it's because of the nil there
has been no
no proof of it
[Music]
DeMille is way over there and why did
they decide all of a sudden to put two
pipe all the way down to the reserved
Masada coincidence to just have no
respect for native people it's been a
struggle for our community for such a
long time
my people never had a voice every time
an elder passes or community member
passes that's another person that
doesn't get to see the end result
yeah they can tell you they can drink
into this and I know
no I do that road yeah
I got many ones
the treatment modality is a septic said
also Oliver
there's lobsters there in mackerel rock
crab scallops snow crab
mission it's not only a job it's a way
of life you know it's something we love
doing you love getting up every morning
go fishing without the fishing industry
you know they're gonna be a ghost town
around here
all our money we make we spend locally
and in the mill their profits they go
overseas
[Music]
we're not backing down we'll see fight
breakdown
[Music]